in this heat fire is almost an
inevitability a blaze at licki hills in
worcestershire has covered nearly half a
square kilometer with four fire crews
working to stop it spreading more
further south it's been hotter still
with temperatures exceeding 38 degrees
in some places
cambridge holds the uk heat record set
here in 2019
it was only a degree below that today
the local museum has opened its doors to
allow visitors some respite from the
heat that this town never experienced
before the 21st century
it feels like a wall of heat is it nice
to be in here out of the heat
yes yes
it
in the is countryside they were
harvesting in the early hours but in
this heat they're heading in
the wheat is so dry they're losing
around 50 pounds on every hectare
gathered
already some parts of the uk have seen
temperatures higher than they have ever
seen before and with climate change
pushing up average temperatures
heat waves like this are only becoming
more frequent and they can continue to
do so in future that's already changing
the way we live and how we work
i've been working on the farm about 12
years in my mind harvest finishes at the
end of august beginning of september
but actually more and more recently
we've been having it finishing in early
august it's not out of the question this
year that we'll finish in july
already in the last few years we've seen
things changing significantly
extreme heat like this is driven by
large-scale weather patterns but average
temperatures are set to continue to rise
for decades increasing the risks in our
climate here in the uk there is a place
for enjoying fine summer weather but
situations like we're experienced this
week is not that case
so this is a severe and extreme weather
event that people need to take action
and respond to and climate change is
making this type of weather more likely
to occur
in stockport volunteers were taking food
parcels to those advised not to venture
out in this potentially deadly weather
thank you very much
walters today yeah thank you okay thanks
very much really hot
extremely hot unbearably hot to be
honest also i've got a walkthrough i
can't really walk very far so i'm like
i'm pretty much isolated in it so i'm
just sitting in the stifling heat to be
honest
a boy of 16 died after getting into
difficulty in bray lake near maidenhead
in berkshire the fourth person to drown
in the heatwave so far
calls to london ambulance service were
already up 30
due to last week's heat
not surprisingly they're seeing even
more calls now
extra resource has been put in place the
contingency plans that are well
established have been activated
and we're meeting
regularly with nhs leaders with
ambulance chief execs to closely monitor
the impacts and particularly the
handover
times
so we can mitigate those with the
increased pressure they're facing
even after sunset it's expected to
remain close to 30 in many places an
uncomfortable night ahead of tomorrow
when temperatures are forecast to exceed
40 degrees
bringing a new chapter to the uk's
climate history
tom clark sky news cambridgeshire